huh I got a little emotional when you
ask me the question being a multiracial
Asian affects everything about my life
my culture is a mix of not just being
black and Asian but also there's like a
third thing that's not either of those I
haven't felt like I really fit in with
either one of my cultures because I
didn't really look like my mom or my dad
on one hand I was able to experience
some white privilege and on the other
hand I experienced certain prejudices
and stereotypes of also being Asian we
grew up being referred to as hapa Holly
and as I grew it became more of a widely
accepted term for anyone who was
partying it's been appropriated by a
broader audience I have mixed feelings
when I hear the term hop at least
there's a way to acknowledge that not
everybody is just one thing or another
people will say like oh you're white
because you're not acting black or
because these things that you do aren't
black they must be white and that's
annoying because I'm not white evening
often when I meet people the very first
question I get is where are you from it
confuses people because they usually
associate being American with being
white they don't really know how to
react and it usually comes off as
offensive they think that it'll give
them some insight into Who I am as a
person my cultural identity is a part of
me but it doesn't affect Who I am really
as a person I was once on a date with a
guy and he asked the what are you
question so I you know explained my
ethnicity and he was still kind of
confused and then like mixing up the
different types of Asian it was like oh
you know is your mom Chinese and I was
like I just said I was Japanese I was
just like having lunch with one of my
friends
and he introduced me to another friend
of his who also from Thailand he was
like oh yeah this is my friend you know
Aaron he's Thai and she is like no it
was just annoying that that was the way
that we met it not only makes me feel
uncomfortable but it makes me feel as if
I'm sort of other and it sort of just
disconnects me and feels like I'm taken
out of the equation and put in a
specific box and it feels really lonely
there are times where it feels like the
questions reflect their own inner
stereotypes or prejudice and there is
the opportunity to help people through
that and you know help correct some of
those misconceptions when I think about
my grandmother who survived and was able
to endure so much when she was there and
then come to this country not speaking
English and be successful and have a
great life and pass all of that on to me
I feel very very proud I'm proud to be
multiracial because I have two different
cultures that I'm a part of I'm no
longer ashamed of not looking a certain
way I feel like being multiracial is
unique in its own sense more and more
I'm seeing more people representing us
out in the world as far as like actors
or musicians or activists to see other
people who look like me and people who
have had the same experiences as me
making big changes out in the world is
really inspiring when my parents were
young parents it was still pretty rare
to see mixed-race couples people would
ask my mom like are you babysitting I'm
proud of my parents for following their
hearts and loving someone who there may
have been social pressure to not love
and then also raising us with the
understanding that love is not about a
race it's about who you love if I could
give a message to someone just like me I
would tell them to not be ashamed of who
they are and to love all parts of
themself and where they come from you
have to define for yourself what it
means to be
mixed race your individual experience of
your own culture and your own family
your own history and how all of that
affects you today is totally up to you
you are special and different but in a
really awesome way and if anyone tries
to make you feel like that difference is
not okay or as other or is bad in any
way you know just don't listen to them
there would be periods in my life where
I would try really hard to be just one
part of myself so there were phases
where I just would try to be very light
and then other times where I would try
to be more like the Asian kids and I
think that's a part of like finding your
identity when you are mixed-race you
also need to find people whether they're
multiracial or not who will celebrate
you for who you are and help you in your
discovery of who you are who you want to
be sometimes when we talk about people
who are multiracial we talk about them
as being part something or being half
something and I know it's just words but
at the same time I feel like we should
embrace the idea that though your
blood-quantum may be a certain amount of
another group it doesn't make you less
you're a full Hawaiian you are a full
Asian you are a full European you should
be able to feel like a full member of
all those different parts
[Music]